une cellule terroriste féminine a été
démantelé hier en tunisie selon les
autorités locales à ce groupe affilié à
la branche armée de dèche au maghreb ne
vais recruter un maximum de femmes via
les réseaux sociaux pour les envoyer
ensuite vers un groupuscule retranchés
dans les montagnes de l'ouest tunisien
fut le point avec notre correspondant à
tunis bassem chips cela faisait plus de
sept mois que les unités antiterroristes
de la garde nationale tunisienne elle
n'avait pas procédé au démantèlement
d'une cellule jihadiste en tunisie hier
le ministère de l'intérieur a annoncé
via sa page officielle
la découverte d'une cellule féminine qui
opérait entre les gouvernorats du kef à
l'ouest du pays et de tozeur dans le sud
via le réseau social facebook ces femmes
soldats recrutés au nom de jeunes elle
rallie pas groupes terroristes affiliés
à des shs de nouvelles à volontaires
tunisienne dans le but de grossir les
rangs des soldats du califat retranchés
dans les montagnes de l'ouest du pays
traduites devant le parquet du pôle
judiciaire de lutte contre le terrorisme
des mandats de dépôt ont été émis à
l'encontre de ces femmes dont ni le
nombre ni l'identité n'a pour le moment
été révélée le ministère de l'intérieur
a également fait état de l'arrestation
d'un élément takfiri originaire du
gouvernorat de bizerte au nord du pays
est active dans ce que les unités
antiterroristes de la garde nationale
appelle l médiatique de dèche accusé de
renseignement propagande et incitation à
la guerre sainte cet homme dont
l'identité n'a pas été révélée a
également été placé sous mandat de dépôt
par la justice tunisienne selon le
colonel majeur houssameddine chablis
porte parole de la direction générale de
la garde nationale en avril dernier
ahmed douib l'un des cerveaux de cette
branche terroriste en tunisie avaient
été abattus par les forces de sécurité
du pays affaiblie sans davantage des
opérations menées par le groupe daher en
tunisie selon les ong internationales à
christus groupe les groupes terroristes
affiliés à al qaïda et des bases et en
tunisie ont perdu les deux tiers de nos
effectifs depuis 2006